hola de nuevo bueno vamos a seguir con
la presentación de triángulos 40 y 55 90
así que voy a borrar todo esto ahora en
la última presentación aprendimos que
cualquier lado de un triángulo 45 45 90
cualquier lado que no sea la hipotenusa
es igual a raíz de 2 sobre 2 raíz de 2
sobre 2 por ser la hipotenusa así que
bueno hagamos unos cuantos problemas más
y si yo te dijera que la hipotenusa de
este triángulo bueno una vez más te voy
a recordar que esto solamente funciona
para triángulos 45 45 90 si éste mide 45
también éste debe medir 45 si yo te digo
que la hipotenusa que mide digamos que
10 entonces mide 10 y sabemos que que
éste repote nusa porque bueno es el lado
opuesto al ángulo de 90 grados así que
luego te preguntaría yo sobre este lado
x cuánto mide así que sabemos que x es
igual a raíz de 2 sobre 2 por la
hipotenusa así que quise es igual a 10
no de hecho no por qué
5 raíz de 2 porque 10 sobre 12 5
entonces 5 raíz de 2 eso es igual a
equis y sabemos que estos dos lados son
igual sabemos que este es un triángulo
isósceles así que bueno porque estos dos
lados tienen la misma longitud por lo
tanto también este lado tiene longitud 5
raíz de 2 y si tienes un duda sobre esto
bueno hagámoslo así que por el teorema
de pitágoras sabemos que 5 raíz de 2 al
cuadrado más 5 raíz de 2 al cuadrado es
igual a la hipotenusa al cuadrado la
hipotenusa mide 10 entonces es igual a
100 y esto es igual a 25 por 12 50 más
25 por 12 50 entonces de acá este lado
es igual a 100 y es igual a 100 entonces
por lo tanto bueno funcionó lo que
hicimos es correcto todo lo que hemos
hecho probamos que usando el teorema de
pitágoras
aunque de hecho así es como vamos a
llegar a la fórmula en primer lugar y si
no recuerdas bueno si no sabes cómo
llegué yo a esto puedes ver otra
presentación de las anteriores que dicen
y ahí hago todo eso así que bueno por
ahora voy a voy a introducir un nuevo
tipo de triángulo y lo voy a hacer de la
misma manera voy a poner un problema
luego voy a usar el teorema de pitágoras
vamos a averiguar de esa manera el resto
así que este es otro tipo de triángulo
llamado triángulo 30 60 90
si no me da tiempo de terminar este
vídeo haré otra presentación así que
digamos que este es un triángulo
rectángulo
así aunque no me quedo no me quedo muy
bonito pero bueno este es un uso ángulo
recto hay que trabajar con lo que
tenemos aquí es un ángulo de 30 grados
este mide 30 grados y sabemos que la
suma de los ángulos internos de un
triángulo suman 180 así que digamos que
bueno este mide 30 este mide en este
vídeo x así que x más 30 más 90 es igual
a 180 porque la suma de los ángulos
internos de un triángulo suman 180 así
que x es igual a 60 así que sabemos que
x mide 60 y bueno x por eso se le llama
un triángulo 30 60 90 porque es la media
de los ángulos internos así que si yo te
digo que la hipotenusa de este triángulo
llamémosle la hipotenusa en lugar de cm
h así que h yo te digo yo quiero saber
cuánto mide el otro lado así que con
cómo hacemos eso bueno podríamos hacerlo
usando el teorema de pitágoras así que
voy a dibujar voy a hacer aquí un
pequeño truco ojalá te gusta entonces
magia voy a dibujar una copia de este
triángulo así que bueno pero lo voy a
dibujar como reflejado en un espejo lo
voy a dibujar del otro lado este es el
mismo triángulo pero solamente volteado
en la otra dirección entonces esto mide
de 90 y sabemos que estos dos ángulos
son suplementarios porque porque son
ángulos que suman 180 están en esta
línea entonces bueno este es un este es
de 90 también este de 90 y como los
volteamos es totalmente simétrico estos
dos triángulos son exactamente el mismo
triángulo solamente que volteado este
ángulo también mide 30 grados y también
este ángulo de acá me de 60 grados ahora
si este ángulo mide 30 y también este
otro ángulo mide 30 sabemos que este
ángulo este ángulo más grande que va
desde desde aquí hasta acá es también de
60 y si este ángulo mide 60 entonces
este ángulo de arriba es de 60 y este
ángulo de cadera derecha es también de
60 entonces sabemos que por el teorema
que vimos cuando yo hablé sobre
triángulos de 40 y 55 90 que si estos
dos ángulos miden lo mismo a los lados
que no comparten también miden lo mismo
y cuáles son los datos que no comparten
bueno pues serían serían este este de
aquí y estoy acá cierto así que claro
que sí que es exacto este lado es h y
este lado también es h ahora este ángulo
mide 60 y si observamos también este
ángulo de abajo mide 60 sabemos que los
lados que no comparten también son igual
ahora comparten este lado así que los
lados que no comparten serían este lado
y este lado por lo tanto también éste
mide h también este lado mide h entonces
resulta que si tú tienes 60 70 y 60 a
todos lados todos los lados miden lo
mismo así que tenemos aquí un triángulo
equilátero
y eso es muy importante tener en mente
porque bueno si tú tienes tiene mucho
sentido porque es un triángulo
equilátero un triángulo equilátero es
simétrico no importa como tú lo veas
pero bueno originalmente que iniciamos
con un problema donde solamente teníamos
la mitad de un triángulo equilátero
entonces sabemos que todo este lado mide
h todo este lado mide h
si todo este lado mide h entonces este
pequeño lado bueno esta es la mitad de h
cierto y bueno mil disculpas por todo el
rider o que estoy haciendo
tal vez cambio de color mejor así que
esto mide la mitad de ese lado así que
bueno esto es h sobre 2 y también este
lado mide h sobre 2 y si nos regresamos
a nuestro triángulo original bueno
dijimos que este ángulo de acá mide 30
am que esto era la hipotenusa es la
hipotenusa y que este ángulo es un
ángulo recto
sabemos que el lado opuesto al ángulo de
30 grados mide la mitad de la hipotenusa
y bueno como fue que sabemos eso
duplicamos el triángulo a un triángulo
equilátero donde bueno todo este lado
debe medir la misma lo mismo que la
hipotenusa y este es la mitad de este
lado así que esta es la mitad de la
hipotenusa así que bueno recordemos eso
el lado el lado opuesto al ángulo de 30
grados es la mitad de la hipotenusa voy
a dibujar en esto otra vez porque está
esta página se está poniendo un poco y
bueno ya así que bueno regresando lo que
tenía originalmente
este es un ángulo recto y esta es la
hipotenusa la hipotenusa aquí está este
ángulo mide 30 grados
entonces bueno acabo de llegar a que el
lado opuesto al ángulo de 30 grados o
sea este lado debe medir la mitad de la
hipotenusa así que esto es un medio un
medio por h y si esto mide la mitad de
la hipotenusa entonces bueno cuánto mide
esto aquí es donde usamos en muy bien
conocido teorema de pitágoras sabemos
que este lado este lado al cuadrado más
este lado al cuadrado es igual a la
hipotenusa al cuadrado llamemos a este
lado a así que tenemos entonces lo
escribo acá arriba tenemos un medio por
h al cuadrado por h al cuadrado más al
cuadrado es igual a h al cuadrado
entonces esto es igual a h al cuadrado
sobre 4 más al cuadrado es igual a h al
cuadrado si restamos h al cuadrado de
ambos lados obtenemos al cuadrado
es igual a h al cuadrado menos h al
cuadrado sobre 4 lo cual es igual a h al
cuadrado por uno menos un cuarto es
igual a tres cuartos por h al cuadrado y
esto es igual a al cuadrado así que esto
es igual a chará ya alcanza ya no ya no
tengo espacio
lo voy a hacer acá arriba
entonces bueno tomo la raíz cuadrada de
ambos lados obtengo que es igual a la
raíz de tres cuartos entonces es lo
mismo que raíz de tres sobre dos luego
la raíz de h al cuadrado es igual a
simplemente h entonces x por h y bueno
ahora esta no es no es de área es d es
la longitud de este lado tal vez no fue
muy buena idea
usar esta a pero well en fin ya ya lo
hice así que esto es igual a raíz de 3
sobre 2 por h y bueno ahí están
todos los datos relacionados a la
hipotenusa de un triángulo 30 60 90
entonces si este ángulo mide 60 entonces
ya sabemos cuánto mide la hipotenusa y
sabemos que un triángulo 30 60 90
sabemos que el lado opuesto al ángulo de
30 grados debe medir un medio de la
hipotenusa y sabemos que el lado opuesto
al ángulo de 60 grados mide raíz de 3
sobre 2 por la hipotenusa entonces bueno
en el próximo vídeo voy a mostrarte cómo
usando bueno de hecho tal vez quiero
memorizar esto tal vez no lo quiero
demonizar pero sería memorizar as porque
podrás resolver problemas de aptitud de
una manera muy rápida y bueno es bueno
usar esta información porque ya puede
resolver problemas de sobre triángulos
30 60 90 de una manera bastante rápida